this is a production of cornell
university as we've been saying
welcome everybody this is episode 19 of
the cornell turks show
this spring fastest 30 minutes in turf
again i don't know if
this is really faster than any other 30
minutes but we like to think so
our guest today dr grady miller from nc
state university
uh we're going to talk a mowers today uh
clippings uh
it'll be interesting we'll talk about
mulching mowers and
and uh side ejection all that sort of
stuff so stay tuned for that but
as always frank uh frank will start us
off with uh
some interesting tidbits for the week
for our video audience and maybe a
weather review as well
well grady here's a natural mower right
cage up the rabbit feed them walk them
around the yard and that's one way to go
so welcome to the show everybody
uh really appreciate all of you joining
us live those of you watching the video
listening on the podcast uh this should
be a good
discussion about something that in my
opinion just doesn't get discussed
enough
and oddly enough is one of the most
common things we do
i had to give a shout out to dr jesse
benelli who has a twitter account for
his front lawn
you have to admire the passion of turf
people to do this
and and setting up a little golf course
there but in honor of talking about
mowing you know dr benelli may need to
do some uh
sharpening of that mower blade so so
we'll get back to
mowing in a second just a news update we
gave the uh golf guys this yesterday
talk about a little bit today it's it
wouldn't be springtime for most of us in
in the northeast if we weren't talking
about weeds and all the people who study
this for a living
once a year are surveyed for the most
common and most troublesome right common
is what you see troublesome
is uh how hard they are to control and
and the survey says uh in our field of
of turf and pasture stuff
uh the most common or probably no
surprise to you
and then you see in the most troublesome
the dandelion the white clover drop off
and pass balum and ground ivy uh
join join the fray but but crab grass
and nuts edge
uh annual bluegrass uh continue to
persist as most troublesome weeds so
that obviously
creates enormous challenges and i think
i said we had
matt elmore on the show a couple of
weeks ago and matt was talking about how
many of these troublesome weeds
particularly in the nutsedge bluegrass
area uh past balum area as well
they're starting to evade our
pre-emergent crab grass strategy that
we've had in place now
for the better part of 40 years we're
starting to see the potential impact the
climate on this
but for sure the weed spectrum is
starting to get a little bit more
complicated so
crabgrass germination plugs along uh
most of you should see active
germination in the new york metropolitan
area
and and into jersey and central pa where
the elevations aren't impacting
uh down in north carolina well past
the crab grass is probably making up
some lawns down there
at this stage of the game and the first
city is now with the warm temperatures
coming will really start to turn and
you'll start to see this happen
in upstate new york so the phenological
indicators this year
uh i would say they're a good benchmark
the prediction models
also generally good benchmarks uh but in
general
i think neither one of these were were
as as exacting as maybe we would think
they would be
uh and they're good just times to get it
you know give us an
opportunity to look for these things
like a good ipm program would suggest
um lawns that are looking like this you
know i hate seeing them like this sort
of indicates there was grass there at
one point
uh they just don't seem to be
progressing as well
uh and and you know this is an
indication of just maybe the wrong grass
maybe a bad soil
uh you wonder if you sprayed it out uh
would the grass come back with a little
bit of tender loving care you know
obviously
a lot of lawn and grounds people get in
there and aerate and do all this other
stuff and if certainly if there's a soil
issue
you might do that but in general a lot
of times a
a timely herbicide application and of
course the best time to do it
is of course in the fall uh and then
maybe some water
and and uh fertilizer at this time
because really it's an ideal time for
for growing grass now as we mentioned uh
if you're doing springtime weed control
this is the maps for the end of next
week right this is basically our
predictions
for broadleaf uh dandelion control
particularly with 24d based on a growing
degree day model developed in the
midwest
and validated in some places and again
this certainly isn't the ideal time for
perennial broadleaf weed control
but if you're going to do it and you're
using either of these formulations the
models on the forecast website provide
excellent targeted times for when these
things will work
now a lot of people a lot of homeowners
even commercial people
in the spread it and forget it world you
know where you put fertilizer weed
control
and insecticides all in the same thing
you know sometimes that makes sense but
a lot of times the timing for those
things are not ideal
uh so i just remind you again you know
these are not always the best
strategies especially in a professional
environment
where you have the opportunity to
provide a little bit more
uh precise care in taking care of things
now uh another news item noah noah's
come out with a
uh update of their normal uh
temperature conditions uh every 10 years
they get reevaluated they've just been
done again recently
and a slide was made by climate central
here
that was looking at 30-year periods in
the beginning and
end of the previous century and the end
of the last century and the beginning of
this century
and you can see no matter how you look
at the data except for a couple of
very interesting states here gulf coast
states
that are a couple of outliers relative
to being cool
but the rest of us uh throughout the
country have seen
normal getting warmer so when we say
you know compared to normal as i'll do
in a second
you know what does that mean frank what
is normal well
normal is that 30-year average well as
that 30-year average gets
warmer being warmer than normal is
even warmer than you'd think it is and
cooler than normal
is maybe like well what it felt like 30
years ago or 40 years ago so
we're obviously seeing a big shift in
these kinds of uh
weather conditions moving forward now
you know what does that mean
for uh growing seasons i think it's
always very interesting to look at these
things
you look at the length of the growing
season we expect to see
uh you know how it's changed from 1895
to
2015 and you see we're probably
about 10 days longer but you look at
other parts of the country
particularly out west where we're
continuing to see warm dry conditions
really really lengthening of the growing
seasons out there so how's it been so
far this year well
no surprise it's been warm uh and
that has been indicated in the phenology
index that indicates flowering plants
spring leaf index in this case
and you can see while we're doing pretty
well my colleague down in north carolina
has been a little bit uh
on the cooler side of normal i think uh
that cool weather's gone through and and
stuck
around there for a little bit now for us
the past week
was actually quite well below normal
across the board the only normal
conditions we had
were up along the coast of cape cod
massachusetts new hampshire and maine
every place else was cooler than normal
out in the buffalo area as much as 12 to
14 degrees cooler than normal
and you can see there's been a big shift
in soil temperatures
where the majority of the soils
throughout the northeast last week were
almost
well into the 50s low 60s now you can
see within a week of cooler temperatures
a little bit of rainfall
temperatures starting to cool off but
obviously on the whole
we continue to see conditions warm so
again we're still
at maybe a little bit behind but you can
see buffalo remains
quite a bit ahead of normal and it looks
like temperatures for the coming week
are going to continue to be
above normal looking at the the
projections from noaa moving forward
same with rainfall except the opposite
we've had a little bit of rainfall the
last couple of weeks that's helped
combat some of the dry weather as you
remember we had a pretty dry winter
and now we started out a little bit wet
and it's not looking good for rainfall
moving forward we're starting to get
into this pattern
of below normal rainfall for the next
week which might be welcome for many
certainly for us here at the cornell
golf course
but when you look at temperatures this
is the outlook made back in
april for the months heading into july
and they're looking like a strong
probability of very warm conditions
warmer than normal for most of us in the
northeast now
all that said let's move towards the
topic of today which is mowing and
growth
uh and i'm gonna set this up a little
bit by you know reiterating some of the
data that we use
to determine this and of course in the
golf world we're doing a lot of clipping
volume collection and
targeting nutrition around those
conditions
in general we think about it with regard
to growth potential so how much could
the plants
possibly grow based on their
photosynthetic activity at that time
very simple way of looking well you know
the growing season starts when we get to
about 50
um growth potential when the
temperatures are
certainly in the mid 50s low 60s and you
can see now with the expected weather
we're going to be getting
in the next few weeks we're going to be
at full throttle
these plants are not going to be
inhibited from growing unless of course
water becomes limiting now larry stoll
and wendy at pace
turf continue to do excellent jobs in
visualizing this
uh up in the top left is the green is
the high
hundred percent growth potential and you
can see may has been there
uh particularly down in north carolina
uh for for
uh the month of may really looking good
but uh that's for cool season grasses
right
now for right for cool season grasses in
june
uh you see that uh again increased
growth potential we're gonna see
ideal growth potential through much of
the northeast in the coming weeks which
leads to
this kind of a situation where we've got
excess clippings
we talked about this last week or two
weeks ago with sean kister from longwood
gardens
we want to keep these clippings like
fertilizers
off the street in the springtime keep
these streets clean
maximizing the green filter minimizing
the gray
funnel uh and now we get to the question
for
today right because getting that done uh
requires
the proper equipment now professional
turf managers
are going to have a variety of options
both in zero
turn uh mulching side discharge
and and so a survey was done uh not long
ago
looking at uh you know what kind of
mowers do lawn care professionals
uh use or how do they handle their grass
clippings
and you know i was pleased to see in
general at least in this survey very few
of them
in this survey were bagging them that's
a good sign
but there is of course a preponderance
of mulch mowing
compared to side discharge so bring
bring on grady miller
uh with this particular uh study that he
did a few years ago
and it really uh to me of course it
caught my interest because we've done
some
mower evaluation work with consumer
reports over the years and
i've had some personal interaction with
pete sawchuck
the engineer for consumer reports who's
done some of these studies
but essentially you know grady the
question that i want to you know come up
with here and what you studied
is we get this um we get this constant
conversation
about mulch mowing versus side discharge
right
so let's start there first off why did
you do that study
it's like we don't get enough research
in this area so i'm a little bit curious
about
what was your motivation and then you
know take us through what you found what
you learned and then i'll poke around a
couple of questions
yeah yeah so there is a story there so
let me go back
and talk through the story i had a
particular manufacturer contact me and
said hey
you know we we want some information on
on
uh clippings and mowers and how they
handle and
etc will you do a literature review for
us
and sure you know that that shouldn't
take very long you know
so i get in the literature and lo and
behold there's almost nothing written
nothing there's nothing it's a big boy
there's a
couple of engineering type articles and
different things so i go back to them
and say well you need to get some of
your
your fellow manufacturers again let's do
something
and uh so they did they got a couple of
manufacturers together and
and i wrote a proposal up to them and
and they kind of
added some things to et cetera et cetera
and then when we got down to starting
the study
as it got closer they kind of lawyered
up on me
so they made the university sign you
know
pages after pages of agreements that you
can't release this information because
you're going to use a lot of mowers out
there that
we may not want this to get out and i
came back to my city and that's exactly
why i can't find anything in the
literature exactly right
you're your own worst enemy you want
data but you won't let me release the
data
once you find it so that's kind of how
we started so in 2014
uh we were figuring out just techniques
to use and different things so we tested
12
mowers and then in 2015 we tested 30
molars
and then in 2016 we looked at 18
zero turn mowers we started out with
lawn tractors and
then went to zero turns and we to speed
up the process we were actually one year
we tested in three different states
we we transported 30 mowers to florida a
few months later we had 30 mowers in
north carolina
and a few weeks later we had 30 mowers
in wisconsin
so we we did studies in three states one
year which was
pretty interesting to get semi-tractor
trailer loads full of mowers and all
them around the country
and you know it is interesting because
we ran into the same thing when it came
to the real mower research we did a
number of years ago where we were
comparing different heads and
different styles and boy we had a lot of
resistance to letting some of that
information out we had to sign a lot of
ndas if we were going to do any of this
exploratory work so
so that's the first part the second part
that's interesting here is
you know what you looked at why you
decided to look at the things you looked
at like you know
for example you went in with the
assumption that well
mulch mowers cut the grass better
push it into the canopy and that's why
it's why everybody mulch mows
and yet when you got into the details of
this it sort of refuted that a little
bit
but i don't know that it didn't look any
better so
why did you decide to approach it in the
way you did or was that something the
the funders said hey we want you to look
at mulch mowing versus side discharge
yeah well the the funders and those
three studies i just mentioned
uh we were looking at you know mulch
side discharge and bagging
you know the same more set up you know
three different ways
you know the homeowner versions of
mowers and to be quite honest
through the course of those two or three
years and all these studies we were
doing
we were noticing trends and
you got down to the point like we got to
get this information out
so the the study you flashed up there a
few minutes ago
was not supported by those groups ah
i went to our our turf center and wrote
a quick little proposal and said you
know this is what we want to do
we're going to get our own motors
together and we're going to
self-fund it so to speak within our own
funding mechanisms so i can publish it
so that article that you see published
wasn't funded as part of this original
trial that was our own work
because i'd be damned i'm going to get
this information out there
somehow so that design of that study was
building upon our experiences
of all these other lawn tractors and
zero turn mowers
and what we had seen but trying to
really dial in a few things to get it
out in the literature
out published i didn't notice that mulch
mowers
were not performing very good so we
wanted to say well what's
what's the issue there is it clipping
size or you know
you know what is it so that that was the
impetus of that study which we did
publish and
and get that literature out and i know a
lot of people come back to that study
okay so let me let me let me poke let me
poke at you for maybe the stuff that
didn't get published
what did you see when you rode the mulch
mower over the ground
that led you that that said that doesn't
look good
was it clippings was it it didn't cut it
all
uh were you trying excessive things like
consumer reports does take annual rye
grass down
you know three inches in one cut what
was the
patterns or trends you started to see
with mulch mowers
that caught your attention immediately i
just an excess clippings on the surface
i mean we we
measured i don't i have some of my
reports up here on my computer we
measured about 20 different things
uh when we were evaluating the turf but
you know
did it windrow did there was a lot of
clippings underneath
clippings along the edge and we weighed
everything so we actually have numbers
of weights on all those clippings and
then we do visual assessments of what it
looked like the day after
you know so we were mowing these areas
we did most all this work on sod farms
that were very uniformly mowed um
and then you know come back and measure
it the next day
that's when you can really see the
clippings as they start to dry
and you need a lot of grass to do this
you need a lot of grass you need acres
and acres of grass to do
no kidding so you did all this work on
sod farms
yes were there some grant when you did
north and south and
i i want to refer to the study you
published you had tall fescue and zoysia
grass
can you can you speak for a second to
the role that
the kind of grass you cut how the mower
interacts with it are there some blades
that you know this mulch mower was
better on zoysia because it's stiffer
and not as good on tall fescue because
it's more flaccid
did you see anything that was really
telling about the species
because for the people that won't read
the paper yes
those grasses that are more succulent
and kind of sticky and clumpy when
you're mowing them
definitely performed worse across the
board but even worse with some of the
mulching mowers
but certainly you know moisture
conditions do and things like that on
the ground can impact that as well
but rye grass you know how sticky rye
grass can be
you know that's tough on a mower you
know to mow and handle and get rid of
those clippings
and it will tend to clump up inside of
those mulching mowers even worse
than something like a zoysia which
typically is fairly dry
you know as a as a leaf blade and it's
more rigid
even the density is a little bit you
know greater so there's a lot of
different factors with the grass
absolutely okay so i'm going to ask you
to speculate speculate a little bit
with regard to mowers that maybe you
didn't study and a lot of professional
grounds people lawn care people
have rear discharge and
you know you obviously learned some
things about clipping
length and width uh how far it goes
near the edge where it is in the deck
for any of you that want to geek out on
this go get grady's paper that now
you know the story of getting it
published makes it even seem more heroic
i think we talked one time you said you
were out there vacuuming
uh they pre-vacuumed and post-vacuumed
our areas for this
study we published yeah yeah okay so you
developed a method you got the mowers
what would you tell a professional
grounds person
does deck design matter should they just
get the biggest horsepower
and the biggest deck that they can get
for it to be the cleanest cut
is that always the way it goes
uh you you used a few things in there
absolutely yeah first off let me
mention that rear deck discharge um
and i'm only saying this because i have
a rear deck discharge in my house
and those do not do a good job of
distributing clippings
okay you know the side discharge it's a
little bit shorter distance to get it
away from the deck
and there's something about that
throwing action that tends to i think
give you a better quality of dispersion
than shooting it out the back that's
been my own pain
didn't you paint a whole big fat red
strip of paint
to then do digital imagery to assess
the clipping dispersal on the ground
yeah we did that as well
yeah painted the grass red so we could
see it over green and then take digital
images so
we tried a lot of different things it's
actually pretty fun yeah um
okay so so no go so so rear discharge
tend to be popular right because of
safety issues in in professional grounds
yeah on operations but it's interesting
you wouldn't necessarily tell someone
if a mulch mower costs more get a side
discharge
uh well i mean there's reasons for using
different mowers so
selection process safety is certainly
part of that equation
but if you're if you're putting mowing
quality at the top
that's a number one side discharge on
average performs much better than
mulching or rear discharge
i mean and horsepower and the bigger the
engine
the better to cut uh
for the most part yes but i mean
horsepower is not everything okay i mean
what
what is your blade lengths and how many
blades are you spinning with that
horsepower
i mean you have three blades with 15
horsepower and
two blades with 12 you know something
like that so you may actually be
spinning a little bit differently
depending on how many spindles you're
turning without horsepower so all things
aren't
equal but certainly horsepower and
blade spinning speeds and things like
that rpms
does play a role in cut quality and we
saw that i mean some of the
undersized mowers and we saw a few
motors with some manufacturers have
basically the same motor with different
horsepower
engines in it and all things being the
same the same deck
on a larger horsepower engine yes it
performed better it would move the
clippings out quicker
or maybe chop them up a little bit more
but certainly horsepower plays a big
role
and case in point the study that we
published
that commercial walk behind mower uh
which i don't remember the exact
horsepower i have in front of me
actually handle clipping a little bit
better than the commercial
zero turn right on type of mower okay
so this gets to a question i wonder if
it isn't now i'm sure you
you sort of normalize for this but more
and more you see mower manufacturers
touting how
fast you can go how efficient these
things are
what is your if you had to speculate i
got to think the faster you go the worse
this
is have you found any that you felt you
could go fast and still get good
cut uh there's no doubt zero turns
in which are throughout the industry now
versus little lawn tractor types that
you know still a lot of homeowners use
those have been uh designed to mow
quicker
efficiently and still give you a decent
quality of cut
now i can tell you from another
experience when i go to high schools and
they're using zero terms in their
athletic fields
and they're complaining about their
quality the first thing i tell them is
slow that thing down
and you're going to see the cut quality
go up because they're mowing too fast so
so you can certainly use that against
yourself too
so mowing speed does play a role but
there's no doubt that deck design
as you move for manufacturer
manufacturer plays a role in
quality all right all right so listen
before we get to other questions i got
one more and then
carl will open it up and certainly if
you have any commentary
but one of the studies that is out there
done many years ago by our retired
colleague bob sherman at nebraska
is the value of a sharp blade right
and i wonder what your thoughts so i'm
assuming
the blades were ideal every time you did
these studies right to make sure that
yeah you know that wasn't a factor but
that's not the real world as you and i
know from being academics for the better
part of 30 years so
what are your thoughts about how big of
an
impact a sharp blade is knowing what you
saw with really sharp blades every time
uh i think sharp blades are important
they're maybe not
you know at the top of importance uh
because you know you're spinning that
piece of metal so quickly you know i
used to tell people if you could
you know swing a baseball bat hard
enough you could chop a tree down
you know you have enough speed enough
momentum that that
blade whether it's dull or not will make
some difference and certainly cut
quality will help
but it's not going to make a huge
difference whether it cuts the grass or
not so yeah i think blades are important
deck designs are important and go back
to an earlier comment
a lot of our mulch mower decks were
designed to be side discharge and
they're retrofitted to be mulch
decks and i think that's a downside
in the industry i think they've realized
that they may have to redesign some
decks so they want to be just mulching
decks
okay so that's interesting because i
think um
when we've done the work with pete
sawchuck in consumer reports he's had
consistent
uh success with the honda uh hand mower
walk behind mower in the in the consumer
world anyway
and and he talks about how the deck
design is designed for a mulch mower
right and that is true is do you see
that
did you test ones that were clearly
designed
for mulch mowers or were all the ones
you tested
well they were because it was the same
mower for all three things so they were
just adapted
do we have a lot of dedicated mulchers
out there and maybe that's something
they should be doing
i think we're seeing more of them out
there particularly the smaller mowers
uh that are that are just being geared
towards
you know mulching uh and some
manufacturers have figured out we may
need to bolt on some other attachments
to a deck to really
kind of refine it a little bit more so
they they're figuring it out
but they also know that they don't know
that when that mower is sold
they're going to be using a side
discharge or a mulch deck so they're
they like flexibility the built-in as
well so i'm not sure where that will
shake out ultimately
but still you know we we saw side
discharges being the best in quality
getting the clippings away from the
blades getting them out pretty quickly
distributed will give you better cut
quality
that may not be the safest thing to do
environmentally you may be going into
the street you don't want to so there's
other factors involved
but certainly side discharge is still
the probably most efficient way of
dealing with the mower
clipping continuum there perfect perfect
to consider perfect
all right carl that's a great place to
see if there's questions
yeah i think we answered my test
question by tess was asking about blade
designs and i think that speaks to
some of the stuff and and blade speed we
were talking about
but uh i think my final question grady
would be
electric mowers or seeing more battery
powered mowers out there have you
screwed around with anything
of that nature and how does that align
with stuff you've seen from these kind
of traditional gas powered mowers
uh yes and no we did some early work
with some autonomous mowers
those that are battery charged at the
docking station and they go out and mow
for a few hours and come back
we did some early testing for some
companies of those
and you know those are great but
sometimes your grass grows a little
faster
they can handle it and actually it's
kind of picking them over up
and they're not very heavy because of
battery life so you may have to go in
there with a
non you know regular mower to bring it
back down so there are challenges with
those
uh but now as you mentioned the battery
powered and
you know ryobi still has a has a ride on
zero
turn battery powered mower now this team
knows this year
uh more and more i have not messed with
those i mean there's
there's no reason to suspect that they
won't do a good job mowing turf
and i know some of the neighborhoods
near where i live
now the newer neighborhoods that people
don't like to store gasoline so it's an
opportunity to have a mower and not
store
uh fuel um but i mean i
it's like the electric cars i think it's
inevitable these are going to
certainly start catching on more and
more but i have not played around with
it
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu